hey guys welcome to this video in this
tutorial we're going to be building
six different python projects so these
projects are going to be a little bit
above the
beginner's level so you can consider
them as intermediate python project
so right here i have the list of
projects which we're going to be
building so as you can see there are six
projects right here
that we're going to be building in this
tutorial
so guys if you like my tutorial like
this don't forget to check out my
channel at code with tomi
where i teach more on python so having
that said
let's dive straight into this video
hey guys welcome to this tutorial so in
this tutorial
we're going to be using web scraping to
get the image link
of the profile image of a particular
github
account or let's say github user so what
is our program is going to be
doing is that it's going to ask a user
to input the username of a particular
github account
and then it's going to return back to
that same user the
image link to the profile image of that
account in which user
input so let's visualize this
right here i have my own github account
so this right here is my username where
you see tomitoco
or you can also come to the url yeah you
can see that's my username
so this is what we're expecting from a
user so once a user inputs this username
what it's going to get is a link to this
profile image
so as user clicks on that link it takes
the user automatically
to the profile image so let me show you
an
output of what we're going to be
building right here you see
it says impulse github user
i'm just going to import tummy tucker
now you can see it gives me this link
now once i click on this link
i need to open link you can see it takes
me to the profile image of that github
account
now we can do this for various things we
can let's say once a user
gives us the username we can tell the
user how many followers that
particularizer have
or we can tell the user the amount of
repositories or
the the twitter and anything anything
actually we can do with web scraping
so this is a little bit above the basics
of python
that's why i decided to teach this in
this video
so on web scraping
before we start web scraping we need
two things which are requests
and ps4 now these things are python
libraries
these are the most popular python
libraries used in web scraping they make
web scripting a lot easier to
implement in whatever you are building
so
as we as i said there are python
libraries when we want to use a python
library
that is not built in with python we need
to install it using pip
or manually install it or however you
install your libraries
for this video i'm going to use pip to
install requests
on ps4 now to do this i'm going to say
peep install requests
now this is gonna return to my
requirement already satisfied as you can
see
it says requirement already satisfied
that's because i already have it
installed
and the next thing i want to install is
peep
install bs4
now this command line is also gonna
install
this ps4 now this bs4 is uh
let me say is a library but what we need
mainly from this
bs4 is beautiful soup for a beautiful
soup only
so now let me just close this terminal
we have these two libraries installed
now
what do we want to do we want to start
coding now
we want to use these libraries in this
code so the first thing we need to do is
to import those libraries
so i'm going to say import requests
and then the next thing i'm going to do
is to save from
bs4 which we installed i want to import
beautiful soup but as you can see this
beautiful song is kind of
long to type most of the times in our
code
i can just say sbs now what this sbs
does is that
once we import these beautiful soup
function or class or whatever from this
library
whenever i want to use it in our code we
can just simply type bs
instead of typing beautiful soup so i'm
going to show you how what i mean later
in this
session so now
i've imported that what i just want to
do now
is to assign a new variable and this
variable is what is going to collect
the github user so i'm going to say git
up
underscore user should be equals to
input i'm just going to tell the user to
input
github
[Music]
user
now once the user input github user
let's say my username which is tommytoco
it's going to be saved
in this variable now that we have the
github user that design wants to find
now web scraping there are some steps
you need to
do whenever you want to perform web
scraping the first thing you need to do
is to send a request
to that url and as we know the url is
going to be this git up url with the
username the
um whatever our user inputs so we're
going to send a request to that page
and then we're going to get a response
of 200 which means
the request was successful now when we
send a request to that page
what is going to happen is that we're
going to get
the old html code of that page
now once we get the old html code of
that page we can easily get any data we
are looking for
now let's just send a request to that
page
so let's specify url this url
is the page you want to send the request
to so
as we know it is https
[Music]
dot com slash now
i can just easily say slash tummy tucker
but once i say slash tummy tuckle
is gonna be giving me only my own
profile image but that's not what i want
what i want is that it should give me
the profile image of whatever our user
inputs
so now i'm gonna make it dynamic by
inputting this variable
using concatenation so i say https
github.com github user
which is this variable which is what
user input so if the user input any
other thing
it's going to get to that specific url
and then get a response
now let's send the request
so say r equals to requests
dot gets url
so now this is gonna send a request
to this url which is the url
of the user the user input if that makes
sense
so after getting this the next thing we
need to do is to say
sub equals to bs
now right here normally we're supposed
to say equals to beautiful soup or
something like that
but because we've already imported
beautiful soup as
bs we can just easily say bs
and then our dot content
which is this request so we sent a
request if we just say
r instead of r dot content it's just
going to give us a request let's say the
response was 200
but the response was 200 means okay but
the response was
an error or something now if i click
here it says r is a response
but when i say dot content
now this is basically the html source
code everything
on that page the content on that url
so now and then i'm gonna say html
dot parser pass it into an html
code so now that we have
everything all the html on this page
we have it saved in this soup variable
it's very easy right right what we just
need to do is to just basically
print or get that specific
image and we know this image will be in
a tag in an image tag if you're familiar
with html you'll understand what i mean
now i'm just going to say profile
underscore image should be equal to
soup dot find
now here i need to explain a little bit
further now soup.find means
from this html code we have find a
specific tag
with a specific class or with a specific
attribute or something
now when i come back here i'm going to
right click on this my image
and then i'm going to scroll down to
where i see inspect
i hit inspect and what do i see i
see an html code of this page but
because i
right click on this image it's going to
take me to the html code
of that specific image so now
i have what i'm looking for i know that
it is an um this
the url to this my image as you can see
this is the url
it's in an image tag and the attribute
is in
an src so it's an image tag it has an
out of avatar and then the
src is where the image link
is being hidden so
it's very easy now i know that it's in
an
img tag right here that's what we know
and then let's give it some more
information so it knows exactly what
we're looking for
because this can also be an image tag
as it can also be an image um this can
also be an image
this can be an image anything can be an
image if we give it just only this image
it's going to give us back all the
images we have on that page
but what are we looking for we're
looking for this
profile image so let's give our code
some more information so now
let's look for under information we can
say the image tag
which has an out of avatar we know
avatar also means your profile image or
your
display picture or something like that
so
i'm just gonna say comma curly braces
it has an alt
that is equals to avatar
[Music]
now we know what we're looking for so
now
this particular tag is being placed in
this profile image variable if i print
this profile image variable
i'm going to get the wall of this html
tag
but as you know that's not what we're
looking for what we're looking for is
only
this link so what i'm just going to do
give it a little bit of more
information after the world code on that
line
i'm just going to say get the src
attribute
which is where the link is src
so from that tag gets the src attribute
easy and after that i can just print
profile image now
this is all the code we need to write
for this our python program
i hope you understood everything we did
so let me run it
and just let's check it okay let's
delete this terminal
to make things easier and run again
okay good now it tells us to input
github user
i'm just gonna input my username
and then let's wait you can see now that
it just prints
the image link to this username
so once i open this
[Music]
i open the link now you can see it gives
me the link
to my profile image which is very good
which is what we want
so we've accomplished with view to this
program
just let me just quickly have a quick
recap
of what we did so i said from the
beginning we need two libraries for web
scripting
there are also countless libraries we
can use for this
but this is the easiest to implement and
to get started with as a beginner
in web scraping so we say
import requests which is the first
library we need
i'll say from bs4 import beautiful soup
as bs
which i explained why we put as bs which
is just to make it smaller to type
instead of typing beautiful soup now we
added a new variable which was github
user
and then this github user collected the
username
of the github profile we want to get the
image link of
and then we just send we specify the url
which is github.com
that user and then we sent a request to
that url
and then once we got the response we use
beautiful soup to get the particular
html source code
after doing that we now go to the
profile image so
sub dot find image tag alt which is
avatar
give me the src which is the source and
then once we have that in this profile
image we just print it to the user
very good very understandable now i hope
you
got what we did in this tutorial
hey guys welcome to this tutorial in
this tutorial session
we're going to be building a python
program
that is going to bulk rename all the
files in a folder
so what we're going to be building is
like a bulk renamer
python program so this program is going
to go into a particular
folder on our desktop and then it's
going to rename
all the files present in that folder to
whatever we give it
so let me that i would have loved to
show you the output before we start
coding
but there is no way to do that without
having the code right there already so
um let's just go ahead with the coding
phase and we'll see the output when
we're done
so let me just uh go into
the folder so right here in this folder
i have three images with um
different names so
the python program is going to come into
this folder and then rename everything
to let's say
images zero images one this one might be
img0 img1 img2
accordingly that's how it's gonna rename
so it's a bug renamer
uh let me say program let's go ahead and
do this
so we're just gonna import our os just
for python to know the operating system
we are using
so now that python we've imported os
we're going to create a function that is
going to rename multiple files
because as i said this program is going
to rename all the files
present in that folder so it might be
one it might be two
some multiple now we're going to set i
equals to zero
now as a default it sees that the
oh let me say the other files
in that folder is zero so that's why it
says i
e to zero before we do this we first
have to have our function so this
i should be in our function so this is
our function
we can name it main that's the main
function
it doesn't have to take any parameter
so now i is equals to zero and then we
have to specify the path
now this path is the
directory in which the folder is so
i'm going to come to this folder right
here
just something like a bar like a
directory bar we're going to copy it
we come back here and paste so right now
this is the it's just like a url you
know
um www.something.com so this is just the
local
directory where python is going to go
find
our folder but as you can see
um automatically or let me say in
default
when i copied the directory
link or something like that it gives me
in front slash
so if i when i'm done and i run this
while this thing front slash we're gonna
get a unicode
arrow so we need to change all of these
everything like this is in the backslash
sorry for that mistake but we need to
change all of this to a front slash
so like this
we need to change everything to a front
slash
and then the last one to a front slash
now
python knows where to go get all these
files from now i'm just going to use a
for loop to loop through the old file
so say for file name
in os dot list
there of path
so it's getting all the files in this
part and store it as a list
so now we're just going to say my
underscore dest let's just name it as
this variable
should be equals to now what do we want
to save it
as let's just save everything as img
something like img0 img1 img2
so say img
plus string
[Music]
i then plus
does jpg we want to save everything as a
jpg file we can save
it as a png we can save it as tif
anything we want
but yeah we want to save it as jpg so if
you
try to get what i just wrote here this
is a variable yeah
so in this variable well the name is
going to be
img plus string i so as i said this i
it sees the default as zero but since
we're looping through everything
it's gonna get it from zero
one two so it's gonna be img that i for
this first one is gonna be zero so it's
gonna be
does img0.js so it's still going to
remain the jpg
so when we run this you're going to
understand the concept i used right here
so now we can just simply say
my source
[Music]
should be equals to path
plus file name and then
let's now say my test
should now be equals to path
[Music]
plus my test again
so right now let's just rename the
function with everything we've done
we just say os dot rename
[Music]
my source my dist
so now this is just renaming it and then
we increase it so we say this i we have
to increase it
as it's looping through each of it so
say i
plus equals one or we can just say i
equals i plus one or something like that
but this is okay
so then after doing this you know we
need to run this function immediately
the python program is being run so say
if on the scan name
underscore underscore equals to
underscore underscore main on this girl
underscore
let me put a column and right here we
just call that main function
now this is good now i'm just going to
save this file
if i come back here and let me just
refresh this same
your directory you can see that i still
has
this name but now when i come to my code
and then i run my code now you can see
here
it gives me an error so what does it say
it says
file not found system cannot find the
file specified
so it can find this file exactly
what is it looking for now you can see
it's looking for
c slash tests img0
so there's a little problem with the
link
between the path
is trying to find a file named path
so what we need to do is to make sure
that
there is no problem right here so
let's quickly scroll down a little bit
and then right here what we can just
do let's just make sure there's no
problem
[Music]
so osd rename my
source command my disk now this is just
making sure there's no problem
and then everything is a string here
let's start from here
using a for loop for file name in os
does
lists there so
okay now where the problem is coming
from
is um this let's run it again you see
it's going to give us that same error
so right here whenever you're using um
let me say a directory
as i said first of all we need to change
it to front slash
and then we must make sure that the
ending we also add another font slash
now when we run this i'm not going to
have any errors and
everything right here is going to be
renamed to img0
imd1 img2 uh no no no no no like that
so now let's try to do this we run it
it doesn't give us anything right here
as you can see but when i come here you
see everything has been renamed
img0 img1 img2
the jpeg now these is how to
basically bulk rename all the files in a
particular
i'm saying a particular folder
now i can change everything again you
know let me just cancel that
instead of img i can say image and i can
just
let me still leave it as jpeg so now i
change everything to image
i know what i want to do i want to make
this more
so i'm just going to make it a lot of
files
so now you can see we have all those
files i think we have 13 right here now
and then once i just run this first of
all you see everything is img0 mg1 and
d2 copy
now this is going to be renamed from
this when i run it
now just want to make sure that yeah so
it run without any error
now you see img0 i'm in image 0
image 1 2 3 all the way to 12.
now that is how to bulk rename using a
python program
so let's go through what we did in this
tutorial
so we imported os which is going to
allow us to get our operating system
if on the windows or on a mac even on
the linux or whatever
then we just used a function we gave it
main and then we said i equals to zero
now we said the path should be equals to
the directory
which we are looking for and then we use
the for loop
to loop through everything my my desk
this is my desk so like my destination
or something like that
the final name which you want to name it
we gave you that particular format then
we just use all these to make sure we
pass
it and then we use os.rename to rename
it
and then after doing for one we increase
i
by one we look through again all the
wall files
and then we now use this if statement to
make sure that immediately we run this
program
it automatically calls this function and
that's what we did in this tutorial
session
i hope you understood it i hope you
guessed the concept of renaming bug
files
in python
hey guys what's up welcome to this
tutorial um so
in this session we're gonna be building
a weather app so this
weather program is gonna tell you the
current weather situation in a
particular city or a particular location
or country or a town so what we're going
to be building is a program that is
going to ask a user
to input let's say a city or a town
or any location and then it's going to
return to that user
details of the weather situation in that
location
so let's say for example a user inputs
london is going to
tell the user first of all where london
is located and then
the current weather situation right
there
so for us to do this we're gonna be
using
the open maps weather api
open weather maps appear so when i come
here
this is their website
openweathermaps.org
all you just need to do is to sign up so
when you sign
up you log in and you come straight to
api keys
and you're gonna see that you have this
default key
so once you have the default key we're
gonna copy it and then use it in our
code later
but for now let's start with the code
just make sure you have the api key
first of all
then you can follow along so now
what we just need to do is to import
requests
[Music]
now on this request is a python library
for sending requests to
any website so you know we are using the
api of this website
you have to use requests to send a
request
to that website and if you don't have
this just
install it by saying pip install
requests in your terminal
so now we're also going to import
something named
pretty print from big print
import
print so when we send a request to
this page is going to give us a response
in a json format
so when we have that response in the
json format it's always not so
easy to visualize or to read so this
pretty print library
is going turn that json format into like
a tree
you know a what tree or dictionary tree
in which you are going to be able to
read
normally so after that
what we just need to do is to specify a
new variable and name
it api key so something like this
let's leave it blank for now and then
let's add a new variable
and name is city so this will be an
input
from the user and then we're going to
tell the user to
enter a city
so now once we have whatever the user
inputs let's just say
base url which is the url we're gonna
send the response to
then we're gonna do i'm gonna
paste this so this is the url which
we're gonna send the response to
but whenever we're sending this response
to this url we need to send it with our
api
key and we also need to send the
response with the city
we want to get a a response from so
sending a request to this url with our
api k and the
city and we're going to get a response
so
i'm just gonna say plus the api
key so before plus api key this is the
normal url then let's add a parameter by
using
these and you say app
id is equals to
api key like this so we're just
concatenating and making it a perfect
url
so now let's continue with the
concatenation by saying plus
and then let's say and
q which is a query or search or
something like that
then it's now the city so whatever the
user
input now let's see
whether underscore data
because requests dot get
right here let's make sure we're using
the right thing request
dot get base url
dot json
so now request the get base url.json
as i said we're going to get a response
from that url
and it's going to have to be in a json
format so now we have everything we need
about
this current city in a json format but
let's use
pretty print to make sure that it is
readable and it makes sense
so say p print
weather data so this is going to pretty
print the weather data now let's run
this program
right here it says i should enter a city
i enter london
now you can see it says invalid api and
why is that because
right here in the code let me quit this
i said we should leave the api blank for
now
so let me go there and copy my api
this is my api key and paste it there so
remember i said we need this api key so
that's why
you have to come here create an account
log in
come here to api keys and then get your
api
now when we run this we won't get any
error
and then let's say london
now you can see that it gives me
information
about the weather situation in london
so right here entire city london base
station so cloud oh it's giving me all
this the coordinates
um latitude and the longitude
is giving me all this so right yeah it
feels like
273 points is 3d humidity the pressure
the temperature
the temperature marks are minimum the
name
the country the id the sunrise the
sunset
the type the time zone the weather
description the weather is missed and
mainly missed
so the wind is 60 and the speed is 4.12
so it's giving me all this information
which i need
so this is how to use open weather maps
api to get
the current weather situation in any
city in the world now we can try this
for other cities
now let me just run this program again
so
[Music]
entire city let me enter a city like um
delhi i entered delhi in india
now i have this and it also gives me
everything i need to know about delhi
as you can see it says it's from india
so this is basically
how to use this open metal apps api
get it in a json format pretty print it
and then
you can implement it let's say you're
building a web application
a gui our mobile app anything you're
doing you can use
this python program to implement it in
your application
now let's go over what we did
this is pretty simple we just imported
requests
we imported printer print we got our api
key from here
we use the city
variable as an input we make sure we
specify the url
then whether data we sent a request to
that url
and then we got a response and stored
our response in weather data
and then we just pretty printed it that
was simply all we did
now that's going to be all for the
weather with python
hey guys in this tutorial we're going to
be building
a countdown timer program using
python now this program is not to
or this project is not too advanced is
a little above the basics um the reason
why i'm just teaching this is
just to show you how to use the while
loop concept in
some more advanced projects in python so
uh we're going to use white loop
to do this and then we're also going to
use
a python library called time
so before we go into coding let me show
you the output or the final product
of what we are going to be building so
you can see here
it says enter the time in seconds so
this our program is going to ask a user
for
the amount of seconds he wants to count
down to if it's 10 seconds if
it's just one second it was five seconds
it's gonna count from five four three to
one a normal countdown
and then after that it's gonna print a
message let's say like
countdown done or go for a run or
something like that
so let me show you how this works
so now i say three seconds
i hit enter it says three two
one and it says go for a run now now i
can print any message there i can say
i can make let's just say countdown done
or
throw up the fireworks now something
like that so this is how to build a
basic uh
countdown timer is in python let's get
straight into it
so now i'm just going to quit this
terminal
and the first thing i need to do as i
said i'm going to be importing
time time is a python library used
whenever we're dealing with
time obviously so say import
time now after importing time i'm going
to create a new function
and i'm going to name it countdown this
function is going to be what's
going to be handling everything
concerning the countdown
so i'm just gonna say df counts down
and i want this function to take in a
parameter called t
now this t should be the amount of
seconds in which a user wants to count
down to
so we'll put in our column
and then we'll say while
c and then we're just going to say minus
comma section sscs
should be equals to divm od
now i usually call this div mode or i
don't know i just say div mod
and i put t in a matter of 60 seconds so
this is the second is telling you why
isn't the seconds to count down
and now say timer
should be equals to
code then we'll put curly braces
and then 0 to d
and then what i need to do now is to put
a column after this
another color braces and then i'm just
going to say 0 to d
again
and then after this i'm going to say dot
format
[Music]
minutes comma seconds
and then what i don't want to do is you
just print timer
[Music]
and then end should be equals to
[Music]
backslash r now this is just the format
of the syntax of the way
we build this project now i can say time
dot sleep
and i can give it one so after one it
should be done
then t minus equals
one then after this timer is
done i can just say
print
[Music]
timer completed or something else
[Music]
now after this what i just need to do
now
is to ask the user to input the amount
of seconds
say t should be equals to inputs
and the time
in seconds so i want to ask the user for
the amount of time
and then after i know that i'm just
gonna call that function
a countdown function i'm gonna give it
the parameter
int t i'm giving a parameter of t
but making sure that t is first of all
an integer before passing it into this
function
now this is all we need to build this
simple program now let's quickly go
through
everything we just did first of all i
imported time
which i said is the library which deals
with everything about
time in python we are working with
seconds minutes hours days month years
time can do everything
if you want to get the current time
let's say
um the current date and time that from
that
library can do everything you need well
now
we are working on accounts down so once
we have that time
we just defined a new function and named
it countdown
and we made it to taking a parameter
which is t
and then yeah it's in t as a string but
we are making sure that whenever we are
calling that function we are making
using it as an integer
just to avoid any errors so now
after assigning or defining that
function
give it t t is the amount of seconds so
say while t
this means as long as t is still
available
then we just don't say means sex equals
to
div mode t60 which is an integer
then timer then we just give it this
format
then we'll say dot format into minutes
and seconds
so then we just want to print this timer
and end with a backslash r now these are
just the parameters or attributes that
this
time library needs so it's not something
you need to
let me say put on your head if you just
have a notebook or something you can
just write it down
and then keep using it whenever you need
to so
now we can say time.sleep once it's done
and then time minus equals one
so once everything we're done with
configuring it
counts down we can just simply print
timer
completed so the function
is done we're done with the function
then we just
add a new variable named t and then we
took these out to input the time in
seconds so if these are input 60 seconds
it's going to cost us a second
is that input 50 it's going to count 50.
then
we just call that function once we know
what the user wants countdown
integer t now we run this
when we run these it should ask us for
the
amount of time we want to count down in
seconds
so let's wait for this to run this
should be up and running within some
seconds
okay nice so down here okay let me
yeah down here it says enter the time in
seconds
so let me enter eight seconds i hit
enter
so right here it says key error which is
o
zero to d now if we come back
up here it says there's an error
online 15 when
calling that's function and then on line
six
so the error is actually coming from
here
now the reason why there's an error is
simply because we didn't add a column
between 0 to d so this is the format of
time
when we're dealing with this time
library we need to do everything
in the right syntax so whenever you are
using
0 to d the first one represents the
minute the second
represent the seconds so you must make
sure to also
add this column now this was the reason
we are getting this error
let's create this terminal and run it
again
now we shouldn't be having any errors
this time around
now you can see it says enter the time
in seconds we say 8
and then now it starts counting 6 5
4 3 2 1
it says time completed now this is how
to build
a countdown timer using while loop
in python
hey guys so in this tutorial session
we're going to be building a password
generator program
so this um python program is just going
to generate
a very strong password for a user now
let's say user comes to this our program
and then he's gonna like
put in the amount of password he wants
to generate and then it's gonna generate
let's say the user puts in nine and then
he wants to generate
a password with nine characters it's
gonna generate nine password with nine
characters
so let me visualize what we're going to
do so this is the
end product of what we want to build now
the output
you see it says number of passwords now
in here if i type
7 so that means i want to get seven
passwords seven different passwords
and it says password length you know
different sites
let's say you want to create a password
for you want to create a new account on
a site and then you don't know
what password to use so this our program
can
randomly create a very strong password
for a user
so now different sites has different
password characters they need
so now let's say this our platform
requires a character of seven or let me
say eight
at least so if i put eight it's gonna
generate seven
different random passwords with eight
characters each
when i click enter you see it says here
are your passwords
as you can see it gives me all these
random passwords
that are eight characters long now this
is
what we're gonna be doing in this
tutorial session
now you can see that um this is not too
advanced for a python project
but it kind of teaches some things you
need to know
working with python so let's just get
into that
so let me close up this terminal
right here now what i want to do we're
going to import
a python library called random now this
python library we don't need to
install it it's built in with python
so all i just need to do is to say
import random
now once i have this imported what i
need to do next now
i can just print to the user i can do
something like this
print um
password generator
[Music]
let's say welcome to
[Music]
to
your password generator so now this is
just telling the user that
um this is a password generator and then
the next thing we're going to do
is to just simply assign a new variable
so it's going to have something like
charge
now this charge is a string but what is
in this string
is random characters very very random
characters
so we're going to have this variable
called chars what is going to be in here
is
letter a to z in small letter letter a
to z
in capital letters we're also going to
have some random
symbols and we're also going to have 0
to 9
so we're going to compile all this into
one string
and then our password generator is just
going to randomly
pick different characters and mix it up
and provide our password
so you're going to understand this in a
bit let's just continue with what we're
doing
so this characters let me just paste in
what we're going to put
so now i pasted this in
right here you see it says a b c
d e f g h i j
k l m n o p q r s t
u v w x y z so right here
is list from a to z in small letters
the same thing it does here a b c all
the way to z but now
in capital letters and right here you
see that we just have some
symbols or to this place and from here
we have 0 to nine
so we just mixed up all these different
characters together
to so that our password generator
program
can randomly pick any amount from
this long character and give us a strong
password
strong and unique password to be precise
so now that we have that
the next thing we need to do is to have
a new variable and name it number
[Music]
now this number is going to be a
variable which
takes the amount of passwords a user
wants to generate
let's say a user needs five passwords or
six different passwords
now this variable is gonna be
what is gonna tell us how many passwords
should we generate
so now it's just going to be a simple
input
[Music]
and then i can just simply say input
amount of passwords
to generate
so now this is gonna as i explained
earlier
tell us the amount of password the user
wants to generate
and i want to make sure that i convert
this to an integer
because when i'm using it in my function
my function we must see this as an
integer so because we want to get the
amount of something
which is a number so it needs to be an
integer if the string
is going to trust a type error so let's
say
integer of number now we have to collect
another variable
and this one should be length
and now this lens should be the length
of the password let's say the
user wants seven characters or eight
characters
this variable is going to collect it
let me say your password
lens
[Music]
sorry about that
[Music]
so let me just write something like
input
so this is also another variable telling
the user to input the password length
and i also want to make sure to make
this
an integer because as i explained we're
getting the amount of something
the amount of a particular value so we
want to make sure it's an integer so
whenever i using this now function
it gets it as an integer so now
once we have everything we need from the
user let's just print to the user
here are your passwords
so now this is just when the user here
are your password
so after this we're going to use a for
loop to now first of all
get all the passwords the user needs and
then print it to the user
so after here are your passwords what
should be next is
obviously the passwords so now is a very
simple for loop
very very easy one i'm just gonna say
for
pwd it means password just shutting
it to pwd in range and note
this pwd can be anything it can be for p
it can be for d it can be for passwords
and full anything
now i just um use that there just to
denote password because
it makes more sense but that is not a
specific
um let's say it's not a must that that
must be pwd
so that's just a basic concept of for
loop
so for pwd in range of number
so we're getting the range of this
number variable right here
so what i want to do is to set a new
variable and name it passwords
so now these passwords we're going to
leave it empty for now
and then after passwords another for
loop so it's like a nested loop
we'll say 4 c in
range
[Music]
range of length
[Music]
now i want to do say password
plus say passwords
plus equals
random dot choice
then we give it this character variable
so what this is doing
is we are adding random.choice to this
password variable we set right here
so random the choice is this we imported
remember we imported random
now this is just a python module or
library
which gets the random text
from a particular string so i say random
the choice from this character string
which is this so just going to get
random
characters from this string and then
once it has it it's just going to
pass it into this variable which we
assigned earlier
so after doing this now you know what we
just want to do just
print passwords as easy as that
now this is a very easy way to
build a simple password generator
program
using python let's run it and see the
output
now we run it let me quickly kill this
terminal
we run this let me
increase it
so now it says welcome to your password
generator
it asks for the amount of password to
generate let's just generate one
and then input your password length we
want the
amount of characters and the password to
be nine
now when we hit enter it says here are
your passwords
now you see it gives me this password if
i count it
one two three four
five six seven eight nine now it gives
me this
very random and strong password from
our program so it's just automatically
generating a password
now i hope you understood what we did in
this video because it's a very cool
project
which you can implement let's say into
your gui application
or your web application or anything
you're doing so this is just how to
generate a random password from
or using python
so guys in this tutorial section we're
going to be talking about
encoding and decoding qr code in python
so let's first start with encoding qr
code what i mean by a coding qr code is
just
creating a qr code using python that
means creating a qr code and then
filling in some data
with that qr code so when we let that
decode that qr code
it's going to give us back that data so
now
whenever i want to create a qr code in
python
there are various python libraries you
can use but for this video
we're going to be using qr code library
so we can first need to make sure we
have qr code
installed let's us open up a new
terminal
and then okay i have an existing
terminal so i'm just going to say
pip install qr code
now this command line is going to
install qr code
but for me it says requirement already
satisfied because i have it installed
already
so let's just go ahead and close that up
right now what we just need to do is to
import
qr code like this
now that we have qr code imported we're
going to have a new variable any data
so this data is gonna be um
let's say whatever that qr code is gonna
mean like
whatever that qr code what the data are
going to encode into that qr code
so let's just say the data of this qr
code
is um
[Music]
don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]
also we're dealing with python so we can
put um
[Music]
these
python we see that we want to close it
so we have to put this
backslash and then we can now come here
and then close it
so that's the data we want to include
don't forget to subscribe
and now let's just encode the data into
a new qr code so i'll say make
i'll say img should be equals to
qrcode.make
and then encode it with data
so it's going to encode it with this
data variable and then once we have that
we're just going to save it as an image
file
so say image dot save
[Music]
and then we're going to save it come
here
right here we want to save it in this
folder
so right here we're just going to copy
this particular folder
go back and paste it there so i want to
save it in this folder
and remember that anytime you are
working with directories in python
you need to change this to a font slash
it's always in backslash automatically
so we change it to a front slash same
thing here we have to change it to a
front slash
everywhere so now that we have that done
so i want to save it to this directory i
will name it
my qr code
dot png so now this is going to save it
as my qr code or png
if i come here and refresh here
you see that it's empty it's an empty
folder i come here and then run these
now you see it doesn't give me anything
right here
but if i come here i now see a new
picture named my qr code
so yeah as you can see it is a qr code
image
so that is how to basically create a
simple qr code
but now let's dive deeper let's say i
want to customize our qr code more like
i want to give it let's say a red
coloring or
a particular border size or something
like that
so we're gonna come back to our code
let's close this up and then
we're gonna leave the data the same
don't forget to subscribe
and then what we're just gonna do
right here let me just make sure i copy
this so i don't need to you know write
it again
so from here i can delete so we're
making our data the same
so what we want to do we just want to
basically change
the color and then change like the size
let's say the box size
uh the version of the qr code the border
and stuff like that
so let's create an instance of the qr
code class we'll say qr
equals to qr code
dot q our code
and then let's give it a version
of one let's say we want the version to
be one
and then box
size let's say box size should be 10
and then border should be like five
so now we have that instance then we say
qr dot
add data
of data so it's just adding this data to
the qr code we want to create
with all this information also and then
let's say qr dot make
feet equals true
and then we'll say img should be equal
to qr
dot make
on the skull image
feel
on this color
[Music]
should be equals to red
and then i want the back
color should be equals to white
like this so now i've i have everything
i want to configure
and i'm just going to say image.save
and then we want to save it right here
in this directory
and let's name it my qr code 1 dot png
so we don't have two files colliding so
we run this
it doesn't do anything in the terminal
but when we come here now you see we
have a new qr code
and we can check it's a little bit
smaller
uh this is a little bit bigger i don't
want to open the pictures now
just to keep the video minimal so
as you can see it is red and
the other colors are white as we
configured
so that is um how to basically
encode um some data into a qr code and
design the qr code however we want it so
now we've talked about encoding
now let's talk about decoding the qr
code now you know that we
passing this data which is don't forget
to subscribe
into our qr code but what if we have
this qr code already
and then want to get whatever data is
inside that qr code
now how do we do this let's just
delete all this now for us to decode
a qr code that means get the data
written inside our qr code
we need a python library called pyz
bar now there are a lot of libraries you
can use for this
but for this video and the one i use
personally that i love
is p y z bar so you just need to say pip
install pyz bar to install that
and then as you can see it tells me
requirement already satisfied
because i have it so right here i'm just
gonna say
from p y z
bar dot p y z bar
import decode so i'm going to import the
code
function and then also want to import
pillow so you also need one more python
library called pillow
so you just need to say pip install
pillow so say
from pill
import image
image so the pillow library
to install it you say pip install p i l
o w
but when you are importing we say from
pir import image
so now what image do we want to get the
data of
say store it in a variable so we'll say
image
dot open now we wanted to open
let's paste it my qr code.png which is
this first one
since we wanted to open that
it has opened it already and stored it
in this img variable
so now we just say results there's
a new variable named results now we just
decode
that img which we opened
now that we have everything is just
printed to the screen so results
let's run this you can see
decoded data don't forget to subscribe
the type is qr code you can also do it
for barcode
you know different types of codes rx
these are just telling us
the weights the position but that's not
what we want we just want
data don't forget to subscribe now that
is how to basically decode a qr code
now it's not a must that is a qr code
that you created
you can just take a qr code online and
use this to decode it you know just for
practice purposes
yeah so that is all
about qr codes and coding and
decoding qr code with python
so guys that's gonna be all for this
video i have
learnt something i hope you enjoyed it
uh if you have any questions just drop
it down in the comments i'll make sure
to answer a question
having that said thank you so much for
watching
and bye for now